hello and a warm welcome to this video
series entitled implementation and
scale-up of best practices in healthcare
my name is a Hiram mcnac and I'm the
director for leadership education and
practice at Yale's global health
Leadership Institute I'm joined today by
doctors Leslie Currie and Christina
Talbert Schlegel also of Yale's global
health Leadership Institute and we're
here today to talk about implementation
and scale-up of best practices in
healthcare and to explore a new model
for helping us to manage the
difficulties in this arena
Leslie Christina thank you so much for
joining me perhaps we should start with
getting to know a bit more about you
sure I'm a senior research scientist at
the Yale School of Public Health and a
lecturer at Yale College I'm interested
in the development and implementation of
evidence-based practices innovations of
all types that influence health and
healthcare and I use mixed methods in
this work in this project that we'll
talk about today I was a co-principal
investigator with Elizabeth Bradley also
from the Yale School of Public Health
and we assembled a fantastic team of
very diverse smart motivated committed
team members to help us with this
project so thanks for having us welcome
and i'm christina talbert Schlegel I'm
the senior scientific officer of the
global health Leadership Institute and
also a lecturer at the Yale School of
Public Health my interest is in complex
systems how they work how they change
and how they maintain the status quo
so first what is a complex system it's
really a system of interdependent parts
that are interrelated and they adapt to
changes in each other and occasionally
complex systems exhibit emergent
properties meaning some sudden change in
the entire system so as you might
imagine that definition can apply to
lots of different kinds of complex
systems including healthcare systems
hospitals and also biological systems
like the human body so in working with
the
amazing team on developing the model
we're going to describe today we brought
together a multidisciplinary perspective
about thinking about change and
innovation in complex systems and in
healthcare so I'm very glad to be here
thanks fantastic welcome you both well
Leslie you mentioned the terms
implementation and scale-up and can you
tell us more about what they mean sure
yeah I think it's important to take just
a few minutes to describe the
terminology implementation is
deceptively simple word may be you know
putting something into practice it seems
simple the reality is we really don't do
a very good job of this in healthcare it
in fact takes 17 years on average for
our research to get out there into the
real world and actually make a
difference and caring for patients and
their families this for a lot of reasons
we produce lots of evidence over two
million published articles a year some
of this evidence is ambiguous or even
contradictory and imagine the
practitioner in the field who's just
absorbing all of this data and trying to
make real change in the world and so
implementation is about that process of
getting that evidence out into the real
world scale-up means different things to
different people there are lots of
different terms for scale-up spread
diffusion of innovation people talk
about it in different ways I really like
the definition offered by the World Bank
and this is that the process of scaling
up is expanding adapting and sustaining
practices programs and policies across
different places and over time in order
to affect large numbers of people and I
like it for a couple of reasons it
reminds us that the impact of the
innovation is critical we have to have
successful innovations not everything
should be scaled up and it reminds us
that we're not only talking about very
narrow inner innovations or
interventions and in clinical
environments we're talking about large
programs system redesign policies at
many levels of government and so I think
it's a helpful definition for those
reasons fantastic thank you well there
are hundreds if not thousands of these
kinds of innovations right to help our
audience understand exactly what you're
talking about can you give one or two
examples sure I'd be
one of the innovations that we studied
in the course of developing this model
was an effort to address the need for
patients who have a certain kind of
heart attack from the time they arrive
at the door of the hospital to have a
type of cardiology intervention called
percutaneous coronary intervention so
not a cardiologist but essentially
that's a balloon inserted in an artery
now if that happens within 90 minutes of
the patient arriving at the door to the
hospital they have a much better chance
of having good health outcomes and
sometimes it can even be life-saving
in 2005 less than 50% of patients who
qualified for that procedure we're
getting it within 90 minutes of arriving
at the door to the hospital in 2010 more
than 90 percent of those patients who
qualified we're getting that procedure
within 90 minutes so the innovation
there was actually putting the practices
in place to get door to balloon time
under 90 minutes and it happened in five
years and spread all over the country so
we looked at that as an example of
successful implementation and scale-up
of a healthcare innovation that really
spread all the way across the United
States excellent thank you
maybe I'll offer a really different kind
of example just to give you a sense of
the range of wait environments and areas
in which we think you know the model can
be helpful so a different example is
that of community health workers this is
an approach using lay health workers who
are often you know of a particular
community who have roles that include
primary health care and health promotion
disease prevention kinds of activities
at the community level and community
health workers may be volunteer they may
be paid the models are different in
different environments but very strong
potential to help with primary care
access and quality in underserved areas
all around the world fantastic thank you
so much for sharing so these innovations
sound really exceptional and potentially
beneficial to their communities so
what's making it so difficult well so
as Lesley mentioned change in a system
is really hard and there's been quite a
bit of study on innovation diffusion and
why innovations don't take place one of
the reasons is that systems have evolved
to maintain the status quo to keep
things the way that they are and that
can be function of policies that are in
place the way that people work together
in an organization when somebody says we
don't do things like that around here
that's really maintaining the status quo
and and really resistance to change and
it's a normal part of a system that has
evolved to exist the way that it does
but then that makes it hard to introduce
change and have it stick and and spread
so some of the reasons that we've
understood for innovations to not
succeed in making permanent change can
be for example if an innovation is
introduced into a system by a person or
an entity that's unfamiliar so
organizations have boundaries and
sometimes those can be physical like the
walls of a hospital sometimes they can
be social like membership or who works
there if an innovation is introduced
into a system by someone who doesn't
ordinarily cross the boundary then the
likelihood of it becoming part of the
way things are done is is very low
another reason that innovations tend not
to take hold is if they're conveyed in a
way that doesn't make sense to the
people who are supposed to be using them
so it may be something published in one
of these millions of papers Leslie
mentioned but it's in a language that
people don't really understand it's not
accessible if it's introduced in that
way then people won't use it they they
don't speak that language it's not it's
not familiar to them and then another
reason that innovation may fail to stick
as we say fail to be implemented is if
it doesn't become the normal way that
people do things so this is
well-documented in lots of different
healthcare innovations something can be
introduced into a system maybe a
hospital people do it for a little while
and then it just doesn't become the norm
and it doesn't stick and it's not
permanent so really it didn't become
part of the DNA of the organization so
those are some reasons why change is
hard
thank you so much so the two of you
supported by
you said a multidisciplinary team have
created and developed this model eat it
tell us a bit more about that so I'm
happy to give a brief overview I know
we're going to go into more detail but
the aidid model in essence is a
five-step model that is focused on
understanding an organization or user
group
understanding the innovation that is
being introduced thinking about the
environment around that user group and
facilitating implementation of that
innovation so that it becomes a
permanent part of the way that the user
group does things so there are five
steps as I mentioned assess which is
really understanding the user group
understanding its boundaries
understanding the environment around it
how are things working there when change
happens how does it happen
innovate which is actually tailoring now
that's a focus on the innovation
tailoring and innovation to fit the user
group develop which is to address some
of these environmental factors around
the user group that may serve as
facilitators or barriers for change
engage which is really a deep engagement
with the user group to actually bring
the innovation in make it accessible to
people who'll be using it and work very
closely with the users to make it part
of the DNA of the organization and then
the last step is devolve which is to
spread the innovation to other similar
user groups on existing networks and the
only other thing I'll just mention
briefly is that these steps are really
um nonlinear and interdependent so when
you're developing the environment you
may still be assessing it when you're
innovating to fit you may be working to
engage so that's another major feature
of the model